three-time nominee second you won two
times already and now you're here for
the show that has people losing their
damn minds kevin yellowstone is i've
been telling all the other members of
your cast people are fanatical about
it's not just like fans or casual
watchers folks are fanatical about this
yeah people um
yeah i always thought i had a chance to
be good you never you never can can
predict something that kind of runs away
with with stuff you all you can think to
yourself is if you're going to try to be
a part of something does it have a
chance to
to measure up does it have a chance to
entertain and
i thought that yellowstone did
and uh so it has but the idea you know
where it's gone you don't predict that
kind of thing
season five you guys start shooting in
may
and so what can you tell me about season
the uh
oh
yeah okay well just
you know what you know i'm telling you i
i i take the fun away just give me a
give me a little something i did hear
that it's going to be in two parts i got
a new horse how's that
see
is he this good at keeping secrets all
the time i love it i love it so much so
we we know that you've got a lot of
celeb fans of this show garth and trisha
big fans trisha head on like the
baseball cat judd apatow who else
is a fan a celebrity friend of yours
that we don't know that's a fan of this
[ __ ]
i don't i don't i i know people have
come up to me so i don't really have
that on the tip of my tongue because i
don't kind of deal in the celebrity kind
of thing but i i probably haven't had a
show where i it feels like if i'm out
it's within an hour
it's somebody's going to talk about it
and you kind of hope that happens a
little bit and and it has so it's been
i think it's what happens when you have
great dialogue and you put it against
mountains and
rivers and
running horses i think there's you know
little gold dust on it taylor said he
already knows how he wants to end the
series do you know how you would like to
see it in no i haven't thought about
that
i just hope it just runs its course in a
really
you know fun way
we're a highly dysfunctional family
you know maybe uh
you know maybe the highlight is we get
ours together i don't know well i don't
know about that
you could but do you have a few more
seasons in you
i don't know i mean you just you just
keep you you know how to answer these
questions
i don't know i don't know what the uh
future brings i really don't and kind of
one of the funner things in life to
to know it's a journey and don't always
know everything that's going with it
here's the thing we do know though you
kevin costner does what he wants to do
so
as long as you're having fun you're
still going to do this
yeah i haven't i have other things i'm
going to going gonna be doing i'm kind
of they always kind of feel like secrets
to me and and
just like this one felt like a secret
four years ago i thought it had a chance
to be good
i just didn't know it would be
received the way it has can i take you
back real quick 2022 30th anniversary of
the bodyguard this year
you think about that ever i mean
it was such an iconic movie one of the
best soundtracks ever for a movie
well you know that that song will come
on and it probably is one of those songs
that
people remember where they were at
because it was so unusual the way it
started with you know just acapello
and uh the fact that it was a country
song it was dolly song and the next
thing you know here's whitney houston
and start singing it just without music
and the next thing you know the music
starts and i think we all remember where
that little voice took us